comedians are weighing in on the will
smith chris rock incident with several
coming to the defense of chris praising
him for how he handled the situation
jeff ross called chris a class act on
instagram writing in part i worshiped
chris rock i cried when i saw smith
attack him because i was watching my
idol live at a comedian's worst
nightmare on live television rock should
get a nobel peace prize for keeping his
hands down and not escalating the
situation just jeff also revealed that
he uh he has alopecia but when added uh
when people make jokes i laugh because
that's life because it is and uh
meanwhile howard stern and comedian
nikki glaser weighed in on howard's
radio show on sirius xm
questioning why security did nothing and
allowed will to sit there for the rest
of the show
we'll stand by and watch a guy get
assaulted with no repercussions i like
that they go well chris rock didn't
press any charges why does chris rock
have to press charges everyone saw
an assault take place everyone in the
room with their own eyes and then if you
would have tuned in 20 minutes later you
would have never known that happened
this is a live television event that's
what i was kind of shocked by with how
they kept cutting back and he was still
there and everything was fine and then
he wins and
everyone's a little hesitant at first
and kind of shocked and then by the end
of it everyone's
cheering and on his side but um anyone
who heckles during a comedian's
performance gets kicked out normally you
know
uh i mean i think they were wondering
the same thing everybody else was but
again when you sort of look at the the
that world as a whole it i was not
shocked that they didn't kick him out
you weren't is this because they knew he
was going to get that best actor or do
you think they had nothing to do no that
was i don't think it was ever going to
happen they they were never they were
never no no no no or just escort them
out no absolutely not because that is a
whole other nightmare i think that they
and i'm telling you right now okay the
the way they handle things is to pretend
it didn't happen and they hope it goes
away because that's what that room is
but you have all the stars here and then
behind them you have all of their
publicists
and this is their job is to make all the
bad things these people do go away
and that room was full of people whose
job it is is to just make things go away
and that's why he wasn't removed
scary all right jim carrey and judd
apatow appeared on cbs mornings with jim
saying that he was sickened by the
response inside the dolby theater while
judd weighs in on hollywood's response
as a whole
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore there was some
question today about if anyone else had
walked from the audience and done that
they would have been escorted out by
security or maybe even arrested the
police asked ask chris
to file charges
they asked chris do you want to file
charges and chris apparently said no he
did not
he doesn't want the hassle i i'd i'd
for announced this morning that i was
suing will for 200 million dollars
because that video is going to be there
forever it's going to be ubiquitous
you know that insult is
going to last a very long time i don't
have anything against will smith he's
done great things
but that was not a good moment it casts
a
appall over
everybody's shining moment
doesn't really respond to anything
so i mean if you just look at any issue
hollywood doesn't really respond i wish
i could say that they did people really
shouldn't look for like the best moral
ethical response from the community of
hollywood and i'm part of it but i see
them very very slow to to make any kind
of a choice as a comedian i just worry
that
has a door been opened if you're you see
somebody saying something you don't like
that it opens the door to people think
well
it has happened will smith did it is
does it make it okay well people are on
edge right
it's been a hard couple of years you're
on hair triggers yeah everybody's a
little afraid and it feels like that is
also part of what we're seeing
everywhere like everyone is just a
little off their their game but i think
his apology was great if people read it
i was glad he apologized and i hope that
people really didn't pay attention to it
because it is how we all should be
thinking
so in terms of us asking people if they
think he should have been removed uh
kenzie's saying no he did it for love
paul's saying will should have been
removed
uh
fulani saying how do you know that no
one consoled chris because you know a
lot of people in our comments are are
wondering why nobody
we don't know anything about going to
the story the story goes he the plan was
for him to always uh go back to his
dressing room and then leave immediately
because that was always sort of his plan
according to the that article we quoted
earlier uh but we don't know but we do
know what we saw we don't know what we
didn't see we only know what we saw yeah
which was you know everybody running to
hug will smith to make sure will smith
was okay and tony's saying he should
have been removed and when he won the
oscars something should have somebody
should have accepted it on his behalf
and that's it let the fallout begin
after that i mean i will say i was
thinking of everybody else who won that
night no one's talking about that quest
love one for best documentary right
after that's what chris rock was giving
the award out for and like no one was
talking about that no it's just the
whole thing is just so unfortunate i
mean at first you were just like stunned
and almost giggling and now you're just
like yeah what and jim carrey said it
right and it was it's you know jim
carrey's sort of been
in a different jim carrey world these
last couple of years um but it was
interesting to hear jim carrey because
the way that jim carrey talked about
another megastar in that clip when's the
last time you saw somebody in hollywood
who's at the level of jim carrey talk
about somebody else who is at the level
of will smith like that that is never
really never really good point ross
never does that happen that's why that
clip with jim carrey seemed so odd to
listen to because it was somebody on
this level talking about somebody on
this level saying if that happened to me
at soon for 200 million dollars you
never get that because he's part of the
hollywood circle exactly you never and
that was such a rare moment and i think
that we need to acknowledge how rare
that moment was for jim carrey to say
that yeah shelley saying kudos to jim
carrey a a club is just saying hollywood
privilege
there is it's really fascinating really
everyone's comments because you are
absolutely right a lot of people think
no he should not have been removed or
and other people are saying they should
have i don't think i'm not saying that i
don't think he should have been no i'm
saying that there was no chance that he
was ever going to be that he was going
to be removed okay was i surprised that
he wasn't removed no yeah wow